thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very special careful
boys we have Colleen back hey
[Applause]
I have called her the care for a girl
somehow
where would you go the question today
where would you go if there were
absolutely no limits upon you
like no government no any whatever you
think is a limit where would you go what
would you do what would you be doing
okay
is there something that you're like [__]
I would do it but I can't there's a
tribe right now and I think it's like
Siberia but they heard reindeer and then
they also eat reindeer raw and there's
pictures online of like just whole kids
and families they have uh they carved
out a reindeer and they're just sitting
in a circle and just eating it raw
they're just carving it out and needing
it I want to try that and also I want to
try
um just living with them for a little
bit to see see how they live yeah I
think it's pretty Siberian cold as [__]
bro yeah it might be Mongolia it might
it's just one of those areas
that's where they they sharded I think
really oh really I don't know with the
8080s no I don't know I I like cold now
so right do I have the skills am I
Limited in my skills or is it just
limited in my like resources I think
there's no limitations like if you can
just remove all the things that kept you
from getting there all right I'll tell
you one I want to go to the line Saudi
Arabia where's that that's not exactly
that's not built yet yeah well well now
it is because there's nothing stopping
me two shades there's no limitations
so in Saudi Arabia they're building this
like giant City that's
um basically in between like two like
reflective glass giant walls and it's
all like in a straight line in the
desert and it's self-sustaining and
everything but it's it's nowhere near
being finished okay but if if it was
somehow in existence I would want to go
there because I think that's such a
different freaking thing yeah
no limitations and no problems I want to
see what the [__] happened I want to see
what the [__] they was doing
while it was happening no no now you
want to get a tour from like someone who
knows yeah yeah oh like an Epstein
Island tour guide like a Alcatraz tour
like he ran away from it and he came
back okay so that's interesting actually
yeah that is pretty cool yeah it opens
your minds a little bit too the
possibilities of this prompt yeah I want
to hear from one of the teenagers that
were on the island and then see like
what their life was like there yeah like
what was specifics right you want to
know about every moment it's just like
so when you're hanging out with Bill
Clinton did you guys just like hit
pinatas or what did you do did you sit
in his lap all day yeah you're like or
did you talk about politics you know
like what happened yeah yeah she talked
about like World Government Theory yeah
or like did Bill Clinton give you any
ideas about like what's what's like
being the governor of Arkansas what if
it just was yeah no we actually did a
lot of pinata stuff it was mostly most
mostly you wouldn't believe how many
pinatas are available so bill is
obsessed with tootsie rolls and and
specifically getting them out of pinatas
you gotta practice all the time that
sounds fun no I would want to know
because because that's the whole thing
right it's like well they were
potentially like blackmailing government
officials and flying them in and having
them do stuff and then going we got
tapes I don't want to see the taper I
don't want to see the [__] editing
base yeah I want to see what happened in
there and like somebody just bought it
apparently for like millions of dollars
like what are they gonna do with it yeah
it just happened just happened would you
have any interest in going to see Fort
Knox and what's really inside and how
much if there's actually gold no gold
sucks I like Bitcoin I like crypto like
woo mostly like kuji too for different
reasons
no that would be sick honestly seeing
what's inside a Fort Knox that I mean
didn't Rand Paul like try to try to sue
to find out like what's actually really
yeah or wrongful Rumble
he's like hey what's actually in Fort
Knox and they're like hey [__] you
yeah I remember the equipment it did say
that yeah
I oh Area 51 obviously
is there aliens yes change my answer
that's the next one I was definitely
gonna say Area 51 is definitely gonna
also say like Antarctica because you
know people say that like there's also
like all those all those camps there you
want to talk about that what's what's
the camps over there what's up in
Antarctica a bunch of polar bear camps
no way and they're like humans no what
what's what they said there's Nazi camps
there oh Mazzy Camp yep a lot of Nazis
still
have moved there had kids raised them as
a Nancy it's kind of cold it's cold
extra hateful too it was cool but
there's people in Siberia just there's
just a station there's a couple of
stations in Antarctica well no limits we
just want to find out you know what I
mean there's no no limits no problems
all right I like to
um explore a black cool in space Oh geez
Jesus and be able to come back because
this might be Interstellar no no
limitations bookshelf right
No Limit
ations though we're all like two months
old man if you're like [__] I ended up
in the library I know right that's what
it takes you to the black hole turns
into a bookshelf everybody
it's science and you can't read yeah
you'd be there with tars though at least
it's a low gravity library but still
it's still it's fine it's boring like
you might turn into a Robinson Crusoe
book or something and some sort of space
travels but then your book got canceled
oh that's nice yeah I think that would
as far as no limitations something that
we are we haven't explored yet well
aren't there like some like super Earths
that they found that are too far to get
to that they know that atmosphere for
Earth yeah they know that
atmospherically and element wise it's
super similar they just can't confirm it
physically it's like way bigger it'd be
cool to like go there for a split second
die
different guys
yeah oxygen see that's what we should be
doing oh that sounds so cool I want to
peek and go whoa there's dinosaur
dollars here and they're way bigger than
actual Earth they just they look
identical but they're just like massive
and they're so freaking dream come true
maybe or a nightmare yeah depending on
well no limitation okay okay so
everyone's Vietnamese
so basically you could be like Dr
Manhattan you can breathe yeah you can
breathe I'll I'll just astral project
then because then I can see without
being there and being hurt but then you
could ever prove it because I don't want
a pterodactyl [__] swallowing me and
[__] no no no
a woman's gymnasium
no limitations right nobody
no problems right it's like anything's
like so on the toilet in the woman's
bathroom
I'm gonna be a lady
they're both black holes yeah one's
theoretical
at least mine's is real yeah they're
right recall good call that's fine I
would say I would say that the basic
grounded concept of no limitations to me
oftentimes is like you know what you
know when like you see those [__]
College like hippies that just go
backpacking around Europe okay and in my
mind I'm like don't you have like
responsibility don't you have things
that you need to like tend to or
whatever but the idea of being able to
like backpack through like continents
and not feel some sort of like I need to
be here at home to take care of work or
like like I feel like those are yeah one
time didn't you and Ken just do
something similar almost me and Mike did
uh across the country yeah yeah we gave
ourselves three weeks to just like van
around like the US and stuff which was
honestly one of the greatest experiences
how many states you hit we we did the
most impractical zigzag we probably went
to like 13 different states wow uh we
just went from like New York all the way
down to like Miami all the way back to
like like Louisiana New Orleans then
went up to like South Dakota and Mount
Rushmore which sucks by the way I heard
that yeah so you're just so
underwhelming
what it says that to me I thought maybe
that's like a best kept secret like they
tell you to tell everyone it sucks no
you go there and it's like it would be
like looking at that Sinclair Dino
Gastly signs that bad that's
yeah that's what I'm saying that's
underwhelming
I met a Backpacker um British kid in in
in in Beijing and then I was like damn
dude how did you come up with all this
money and he goes like
um I saved up for two three years I just
like every job that I had because I uh
right after I graduated I wanted a
backpack for a year and I'm like you are
so responsible I blew all my money
that's what I said how much time you
know yeah right but I mean I was in
Beijing traveling with my friends so I
wasn't that irresponsible but I was like
so you took the whole year off to just
travel and he goes yeah like traveling
in Europe is cheap too because they'll
do the Hostile thing for like 10 bucks a
night you know that's what I'm saying
being able to feel like you can get lost
like if you go to a city and then you
like it you're like I'll stay here and
maybe I'll stay here for a month yeah or
if you go to another city and you're
like oh it's cool and I can move on and
just having no like responsibility or
limits I would love that I don't know
how to set something like that up
anymore that's what I'm saying it feels
so far away even though it's like
something that you can do I go to the
Vatican I go to their secret little
Library oh and then I probably get bored
and leave but I would try to look for
cool things
like apparently they have a machine
that'd be funny if you did go there
everything's written in Italian you're
just like well that was fun we're
talking about the anti-matter machine
I'm talking about oh
The Godfather
part of History see your machine
history with the [__] Stargate no
they can see any moment from history at
any point
they have that in the Vatican nah it's
probably [__] but I want to see if
they have it yeah I just want to check
it out because then if they did have it
I would try to see the birth of Christ
and then I would specifically look see
if he's a white guy yeah and I could use
that yeah I could be like hey Christ is
actually a white dude you [__] idiots
but then if he's not a white guy I just
say he's a white guy no matter what he's
always alive
there's also apparently secrets of Egypt
you know what I'm talking about you're
under the pause yeah exactly the ones
that yeah specifically the Egyptian like
government or whatever historical
government keeps a secret they won't let
people in because it has information
about our ancient his human history and
stuff like that that they they're just
holding the secrets of our existence why
are they a Secret Keeper yeah I don't
know it's a secret all the cool Secrets
everyone who's who's about to tell the
secrets dies
didn't they say that the pyramids aren't
fully discovered or explored because
they can go further down yeah that's
what they said they're trying to do so
in our technology right that's just the
tip so that there's other
infrastructures that show
that there's just like
that's the top of the pyramid and then
there's this infrastructure that goes
all the way down and there's reason to
believe that we haven't explored it
fully because there's chambers that keep
going down we never found the clip of
the in a way yeah to use a metaphor yeah
yeah the pyramids right too many booby
traps yeah yeah it didn't hit the G-Spot
we just got tipped in but we didn't get
there
we're still perusing that's so well put
nobody ever said it's very eloquently
thank you yeah you're welcome
which always
let's start so so where the [__] is it
can we get a diagram yeah can someone
show us can someone right ballistics be
involved you're sicko
[Laughter]
I'm thinking if only the show is in
order but that's impossible there's also
there's also for the sake of no
limitations and I'm not going to drown
or anything like that some of the
unexplored parts of the ocean because
what if there really are oh yeah other
species other civilizations very good
you know what I mean that's crazy yeah
for sure there have to be because I saw
wakanda wakanda wakanda yeah and I was
like the third movie imagine
it's really called that yeah
the neck the one that they do about the
Aztec empire it's called wakanda wakanda
wakanda time
the recent one you mean black panther
will kind of forever
wakanda time yeah they brought in the
Aztec Empires and it's really symbolism
between the Mexican and black population
of America yes
but I like Tessa Thompson yeah I really
like I really like them because they're
underneath the Earth and yeah
Nick I was listening to Lex Friedman
talk about he was talking to this one
guy who's the AI you tell me it was AI
Lex Friedman is confirmed it he might be
AI but he was talking to this guy who
was a Amazon Explorer and he was saying
that like all the most Amazon's the most
diverse population of just life right
and he said it's like 70 like
undiscovered nobody knows anything about
it really and he was saying that there
was a tribe of people that would just
kill like researchers they would start
just ripping them apart on the beach
when they would see him and I'm kind of
just like I just want to be a fly on the
wall you know just to watch how these
dudes rip people apart kinda not rip
people apart but just like they're
indigenous right they're they're by
themselves they're isolated I would just
love to kind of just watch this
[__] all the Forbidden places
they're just watching their ass all day
yeah what if it's like they're just like
picking food eating it cooking it he's
got a thing for that though that's why
he wants to see it yeah I'm just like
how do you guys cook that
what do you guys eat over here but the
stories of like how they would just like
kill researchers it's like really scary
it's like that movie The Green Inferno
ever heard that movie oh with Bruce Lee
oh Green Hornet
[Laughter]
they were just they would just like eat
people and rip them apart like it was
crazy they would kill them with their
bare hands it's like kind of really
scary but part of me is like I'm very
interested in that stuff is that bad
does that work yeah it's wrong that's
cool
but the Amazon will be typed to just
kind of walk through and just not worry
about getting bit by spiders or anything
I would go to the [__] Moon and make
sure that we actually went also to the
Moon you want the dark side of the moon
no go to the like Apollo 11 Landings
like if there's Footprints everything's
not suss I just want to make sure it's
alien spaceship That's Heavy I just want
to look about you want to see that flag
plan it's Hollow guys the Moon is hollow
I would want to be a fly on the wall in
like a top level like Berkshire Hathaway
meeting or something oh you get to hear
what they really talk about it's
probably really boring
not more boring than the the the tribe
really dude maybe not more I mean have
you heard Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger in their meetings or just like in
their speeches yeah that's pretty much I
just want to catch them drinking baby
blood dude like Illuminati New World
Order meetings I bet I bet they are
that's yeah this is probably boring yeah
I've been Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger are for three hours talking [__]
about Bitcoin give guaranteed and by the
way sort of found it how about going to
the top floor of like the Scientology
building down oh yeah because they don't
let people go up there right to the Tom
Cruise Suite
I want to see where all the where it all
goes down yeah
remedy Penthouse
I wish I could ride on the whales back
and from Alaska to Hawaii see where they
go because sometimes they they find like
giants go you just said Alaska no but
the deep ocean because sometimes they
find these giant squid in their bellies
yeah
I just want to skip to the part where
the giant squids are yeah
yeah I want to see like the route they
take
I just don't want to watch it's like
nine hours of footage
because I think about as an editor like
I've edited many things and I'm like oh
man we have so much footage and [__]
yeah it's like at least a five second
shot oh God but that tells me the whale
is going really really low
the whale must be going extremely far
like so far down there and I'm like I
don't know how many times I could do
this and clear my ears dude you gotta go
to the James dude
is that what you're saying yeah
if only the show is in order but we
can't figure out how to do that we can
figure out how to put a man on the Move
we can't figure out how to get JK out in
order
that's true it's a distant drill I love
that maybe if we didn't have any
limitations or problems sometimes it's
like the match is lit and then it's just
and and we're here criticizing the
budgets of like City like problems
and we go hey can we get certain videos
at certain times let me check and
nothing happens like like we literally
can't figure it out and I'm like man
it's so crazy to think that like shows
on TV know how to get their shows out in
order but like JK we just can't do it
can you imagine though like you're
watching like Star Trek on TV and then
the fan like episode 10 comes out before
what we're episode two and then and then
the show Runners are just like yeah
that's just how it goes like because we
have editors so like yeah we don't we
don't know we don't choose the uploads
that's what happened this way and we're
just like okay
anyway we can change that yeah yeah
we'll get to it
because then like it's almost like all
the jokes that we make would line up it
all work but like it's like it's almost
like people that know who Christian
Pierce is before he's been in night
videos
well I love that guy that's lovely love
Christian Pierce yeah and now he knows
you love your sister too oh did he find
out about that yeah oh that's cool he
seemed to not react very strongly really
as if he already knew oh he already knew
me before he heard about the bed no he
already knew your sister and yeah
didn't you guys know each other already
yeah
thank you for years how much you love
your sister you probably slipped it when
you guys met each other he seen my
sisters
I mean the one of the first things Steve
always says when you meet people is man
my sister always playing hard to get
always complaining about it thanks for
having me I love the idea that she was
she was actually at my wedding and that
I married Nikki but I was looking at my
sister the whole time that one that is a
gross that one gets me so good that like
that's so gross that one gets me good
thank you